crime-fighting disguise it's a new
phenomenon but it's growing in a brisk
lip then captain metropolis would like
to capitalize on that growth by forming
a team patriots heroes they call
themselves the new Minutemen welcome
back everyone it's Charlie this is gonna
be my watchman episode 6 video they
revealed the true origin of hooded
justice and we went on this crazy trip
so we'll break it all down if you're new
to the channel I'm doing Easter egg
videos for all the Watchmen episodes be
sure to subscribe to get everything
we're also doing an HBO now giveaway -
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the episode on the video
obviously careful for spoilers if you
have not seen the episode yet because
they prevail a whole bunch of secrets
so we'll do top 10 WTF and Easter eggs
as we go along so starting with number
10 the title of the episode the title of
the episode this extraordinary being is
obviously a reference to dr. Manhattan
in present day but because this is about
the origin of hooded justice and he's
supposed to be the original vigilante
the very first person documented to have
been a costumed superhero for example in
the present day of the original Watchmen
comic book the night owl character was
inspired by hooded justice to become a
vigilante because he was a police
officer just like hooded justice turned
out to be a police officer that became a
vigilante
so everything that the Watchmen are
doing in present day flows from the
Minutemen in the Minutemen themselves
were also inspired to become the
Minutemen informed that team because of
what hooded Justice did so he's the
common point of origin for all
vigilantes making him just as special as
someone like dr. Manhattan who is
literally a functional God in the
universe but number 9 the Minutemen TV
show flashback at the beginning of the
episode two hooded justice being
unmasked so not only does this kind of
tell you a little bit about what
eventually happened to hooded justice
with the feds trying to unmask him
because the whole plot with Captain
midnite which they revealed to be true
he really did have a relationship with
Captain midnite but it's a bit of a
callback to PD from the PD pedia that
they're running alongside the website
for the TV show who keeps telling them
that the TV show gets facts wrong about
what really happened like when he was in
the car with Laurie and Angela
the show gets stuff wrong all the time
what really happened was all this and
then he explains the true origin and
what was going on with Laurie's pain and
how her father was the comedian and what
really happened to the original Watchmen
but because we know some of these facts
were real what sounds like happened is
is the captain midnite of the Minutemen
really did try to blackmail Hoover who
they imply really was in a relationship
with him but because the feds want to
cover it up they're looking for someone
who looks a lot like Captain Hoover and
they want to pin it on hooded justice
and they seen him on all the tape that
they found in the safe behind captain
Midnight's bed there was a reference in
an earlier episode two skeletons in the
closet
mostly referencing the Chiefs Klan robes
that he had been keeping secret inside
the safe in his closet but this is also
a bit of a callback to that too Captain
midnite having skeletons in his closet
the meta joke about Hoover in real life
is that he was supposed to have been a
crossdresser but at the same time went
after all kinds of people for their
religious beliefs for their political
affiliation so it's implied that's why
Captain midnite was trying to blackmail
him because he would have been also
going after LGBT people who Captain
midnite was a member of that community
but number 8 the nostalgia trip so
Laurie explains what nostalgia is to
Angela how they implant special
electrodes in their brain then harvest
the memories then later give it to older
people it was meant to be a treatment
for dementia but then became more of a
party drug as people started to take it
people started to get addicted to it and
then they outlawed it but lady Tru owns
the business that makes those pills so
Laurie has just sussed out the
connection between her grandfather and
lady true so now lady true is on their
radar as a person of interest in what's
going on in town but the first big
flashback she has is to her grandfather
being sworn in as a brand-new member of
the NYPD in 1938 right after the Great
Depression but right during the rise of
world war ii and hitler there a couple
references later in the episode to some
comic book stuff around that period -
but number seven he gets the very first
warning beware the Cyclops from the
other black officer so it's already kind
of implied that it's some sort of
insidious conspiracy within the police
so you kind of sense what's going on but
they don't reveal what it's really about
in the whole mind-control plot till
later in the episode one of the first
nights on his beat he runs into that
business owner that's tied to Cyclops
trying to torch a Jewish business and
this sort of sets off the whole idea of
Cyclops within the police department he
sees the other officers stand up for him
publicly with all the other officers
around then make the Cyclops symbol and
you started to get a better sense for
what's going on but number six if you're
a big comic book fan this is actually a
pretty cool easter egg the origin story
of Superman in Action Comics number one
you probably spotted him walking by the
newsstand with the newspaper salesman
reading Action Comics number one
explaining to him the origin story of
Superman the reason why this is not only
a cool comic book Easter Egg because
this is around the time where Superman
debuted in the comics right around World
War Two it's also a bit of a callback to
the Cyclops business owner torching the
Jewish business Superman was created by
Jewish comic book creators they saw a
need for a hero so they created a hero
to serve that need and it's a bit of a
metaphor for the origin story of hooded
justice he sees a need for heroes so he
fills that need only in his case it's
more literal than metaphorical as is the
case with the Superman created by Siegel
and Shuster so within the world of the
Watchmen series there is no Superman
character he is still a fictional comic
book character dr. Manhattan is the
first real genuine superhero with
special powers but if you're a comic
book reader you also probably know about
Doomsday Clock in present day because DC
owns the Watchmen comic-book property
they brought them into the DC Universe
in Doomsday Clock is a big Superman dr.
Manhattan crossover so within the
modern-day version of watchman's comic
book universe Superman is a real person
who exists but you have to remember that
the TV show is based on the original
comic book and when Alan Moore created
that he created it to be very
self-contained there were no other DC or
marvel or any other comic book
superheroes it was just the heroes that
he created within that comic book but
number 5 the true origin of hooded
justice so he goes back after he sees
that the man has been freed because that
whole Cyclops conspiracy and then gets
accosted by the other police officers
that stood up for him and then release
that man they put a mask over his head
and hang him from a tree till he almost
dies then they cut him down and after
they cut the noose
it looks amazingly like hooded justices
costume so he probably picked up
immediately on what was happening the
minute you saw them do that
I saw a lot of you months ago when I was
still posting trailer videos theorized
that his character was secretly hooded
justice in present day because the color
of his clothes are the exact same color
scheme as hooded justices comic book
costume but the real point of origin is
when he's walking back and he hears the
couple that needs his help so he cuts
some holes in the mask so that they
won't find out who he is puts it on and
then beats off the criminals they thank
him and he winds up in the paper the
next day being celebrated for being a
hero number four was hooded justices
first official night out so on his first
night out he decides to go after Cyclops
downtown and finds the business owner
that they had set free earlier that he
had had the run-in with and is all
connected to the Klan he finds all kinds
of maps and details about their
membership going across the United
States implying that the conspiracy is
going on all over the country not just
here in New York City then as he fights
his way into the front of the business
it actually turns into a version of the
original Minutemen TV show that they
played earlier this season when they
were talking about the origin of hooded
justice we find out what really happened
during these events and he was actually
jumping out the window instead of
jumping in to escape the business owner
with the shotgun we get a couple more
details about Angela's backstory when
Lori sort of walks into her trip trying
to help her get out with her husband she
was born in Saigon in 1976 we saw a
couple flashbacks to her grandmother at
the end of the episode and then the
teaser for next week's episode so we'll
find out what was going on in Vietnam
when she was growing up pretty soon but
number three the true origin of the
original Minutemen we see captain
metropolis come to visit him after
figuring out that he is hooded justice
they turn it into a funny moment about
trying to hide their real secret
identities but his wife immediately
figures out oh you are the captain
midnite guy he don't work for him you
are the guy but he tells them that
they're forming the Minutemen team and
they were inspired by what he's been
doing for the past couple of months they
apply it hasn't been that long maybe
he's been hooded justice for less than a
year but because the newspapers have
been writing about his exploits and
being a vigilante they were inspired to
become vigilantes themselves and formed
the Minutemen and they want him to join
the team the big WTF here is actually
though the captain midnite says you're
always going to have to wear that mask
because there are definitely some racist
people that are part of the Minutemen
that would
take too kindly to knowing that you are
underneath the mask working with them if
you remember the intro to the Watchmen
movie where they transition from all the
flashbacks with the Minutemen taking
their picture forming the team then the
montage of the present-day Watchmen team
forming and taking their picture they do
a version where they're addressing the
press after taking down this criminal
enterprise and they take that picture
but the events actually happened very
differently from what you remember from
that watchman intro scene will as who
did justice gets ready to tell the press
about this grand conspiracy that he
thinks is going on with the Cyclops
organization in the clan but Captain
midnite stops him
because they need the backing of the
local banks to fund their superhero
exploits in the team so they can
continue to operate as vigilantes
showing the super racist ad basically
telling hooded justice that we can't
tell everyone about all this stuff
that's going on because they're also
kind of racist and they won't like it if
they find out that you're really a black
person later they pay this off when
number two he tries to take down the
local cyclops operation by himself
because when he calls Captain midnite
Captain midnite doesn't want to have
anything to do with it even though he
himself as a member of the LGBTQ
community but the business owner from
earlier in the episode totally doesn't
recognize him
offers to give him a payout or maybe
he's gonna beat him up when he takes
into his warehouse claiming that he's
just going to give him some free meat
shoots him on the spot then puts his
hood on while still wearing his police
officer's uniform and guns down everyone
inside the warehouse behind the local
version of the Cyclops operation but
remember is just the one in New York
City because of all the maps in the Klan
organization it's implied that this is
happening all over the United States
with different cells there's an awesome
payback moment and a callback to earlier
in the episode when he finds the cop who
hung him from the tree he nearly
strangled to death he strangles him out
with the microphone wire he burns the
building down but carries some evidence
home with them and they do this nice
juxtaposition with the flames from Tulsa
and him remembering what happened during
the original massacre whoever did the
transitions in the episode deserves an
award because of the way they shifted
perspective and jumped forward and
backwards in time in blended things from
the past into present-day we found out a
little about why Angela never met her
grandfather before because his wife just
doesn't like how crazy that he's become
is this vigilante person
hooded justice leaves him goes back to
Tulsa with their son and says never
bother us again don't ever try to come
around then number one WTF they finally
reveal what really happened to the chief
at the end of episode 1 he uses a
miniaturized version of that original
hypnotic projector device to hypnotize
the police into forcing him to hang
himself the chief tries to explain that
you don't know what's going on there's
some bigger conspiracy at play and will
reveals that he knows all about cyclops
which obviously i think they're gonna
pay off in another episode or two
because we've actually seen trailer
footage in present day of Laurie being
tied to a chair with this symbol behind
her so this is gonna have something to
do with the conspiracy that's happening
in present-day as well but then you fade
in on lady true who's helping her out of
her trip at her special facility and
it's implied in next week's episode
we're gonna learn what lady trues secret
plan for saving humanity is and we get
our big Ozymandias trial find out what's
going to happen with him next but if you
spotted any other big easter eggs in the
episode that i didn't mention in the
video let me know in the comments my
Rick and Morty episode 3 video will post
next I've also got a new Mandalorian
video that I'm working on that should
post pretty soon too but leave all your
requests in the comments below I'll name
a giveaway winner when I post my next DC
video everybody click here for my
Mandalorian episode 3 video and click
here for my Mandalorian baby Yoda
explainer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you